we saw this clip this morning this is uh
fauci over on uh andrea mitchell's show
on msnbc and again it's very important
to me that you guys when you're watching
msnbc you must keep in mind these people
are broadcasting from a mental
institution they're not well they don't
know what's going on they have a
complete psychotic break from reality
anyway andrea mitchell
asked fauci about the mandates and
listen to what he says and tell me if
you think he's a good guy or a bad guy
there's so much opposition now in
congress and across the states even in
democratic states
governor
whitmer and michigan and other places
it's becoming just a political
chest and the outlook in
the outlook is not at all a sure thing
in the court system
is there any thought of backing off of
that and trying to avoid
you know
all the outcry against it
yeah but you know andrew we really have
to get people vaccinated i mean i
understand and we all understand
how people do not like to be told what
to do they want to make their own choice
and their own free will i get that and i
respect that but these are unusual times
and you can't think only of yourself and
your own personal opinion but you've got
to think about your communal
responsibility to get yourself in your
family and indirectly then the community
protected so i would prefer and we all
would prefer that people would be
voluntarily getting vaccinated but if
they're not going to do that sometimes
you've got to do things that are
unpopular but that clearly supersede
individual choices
and are directed predominantly at the
communal good and that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
requirements
he is not a good man i anthony fauci is
a collectivist he's basically a
communist marxist whatever you want to
call them at this point that you have to
put aside what you think
you have to put aside the autonomy over
your body and your mind why do you have
to do it for the common good
well it seems he might have dropped the
ball on the common good seeing as we're
two years into this thing and he's been
in charge the entire time and if the
vaccines worked i know
no i'm not a scientist
i'm not
if the vaccines worked then if you were
vaccinated and a crazy right-wing white
supremacist lunatic who was unvaccinated
walked past you it wouldn't matter
because you were vaccinated but they
don't even believe in the vaccinations
and they don't even
and they don't believe in the
constitution that's very obvious and
everything he's saying there is
antithetical to everything that the
united states is founded upon by the way
anthony fauci has no power over you do
you know that like yeah he's the head of
the nih he's allowed to make
recommendations and he's allowed to spew
his nonsense on propaganda networks but
he can't force you to do anything yet i
don't know how long that will that will
last i mean the clock is running out
here but this is what i mean and when i
played this clip within the context of
that it's positive it's like enough
enough i've just had enough and i don't
think i'm the only one i've had enough
of this person listening to him as if he
has any right or
it's not even any right i know he has no
right to tell me what to do but at this
point if you give him any
uh of your respect when it comes to any
of this you're making a serious serious
mistake
sometimes you've got to give up in
essence your rights for the communal
good
sometimes you know you shouldn't say
what you think
sometimes you shouldn't do what you
think is right you should just leave it
up to unelected bureaucrats that's what
you should do that's what you should do
or don't that's the positive part